So here is another example on your old aud and you can see for the past 20 days 20 days or so
we have been bearish, right, so
After the formation of ABC right here
ABC
We have this level which gets taken out. So we have the D leg now
So let's drop down to 15 minute time frame and look for a shift and market structure or a certain market structure would be this
So let's see and as you can see price on broke the structure
So this right here is our autoblock
we can see this very well you gap
okay, and
I would go long here put my stop just right here above the low highs right here and
I would target probably this level right here for 2.56 or I could target this level
So let's see how this plays out. So first impartial would be here or
My full target would be here because I only take two or one to two
So you can see price get went back into our POI at 10.30
Which is during the kills and ours and if I play this through
You can see we would have a reactionary block re-entry at this level once again, so
Gonna see price just slide down hits our take profit level for 2.56 and
Even takes out this low right here. So we were if we were in two trades
that would be
I
Around
Seven RR combined, but I do not take trades like that
I will only take one entry
But it really depends on your style if you see a reactionary block
You can take another entry but because she was because sometimes price gonna reverse gonna get two losses for absolutely no reason so
Yeah guys that is the power of ABCD
Okay, of course you just not gonna go on the charts and just
Try this out on live markets you have to back test and you have to train your eyes to see this okay, I can teach you
All the methods, but you have to train your eyes
Okay to see these patterns and and all
Now you see this is this displacement, right?
This is a must
It broke structure with favorite gap and boom
The simple as that so now let me clear some questions you might have in your mind
The very first thing is you have to look for big structures. Okay, the structure can't be
Something like that
It should not be small pullback
Okay, cuz sometimes process gonna do that
what you want to see is
Price give you a bigger pullback something at around 0.5 level of 5
So you draw your fit from bottom to top and if price comes near 0.5, right?
Or slightly above it, you know
You will see when the pullback is great
Okay, so you look for bigger structures you look for a bigger a leg a bigger B leg and bigger C leg
and then you know the D leg so something like that would be prime and
Yeah, just follow the rules so another question that comes to my mind
Yeah, it's really that guys you don't want to look for small structures
So if you have a small structure like that
You have to wait for a bigger pullback. It's gonna look something like this. So boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
Then you have push up
Takes out literally and then you look for market structure shift
So I hope you guys enjoyed this video and let's move on to the next videos